a little over a week ago
I made a video titled 25 things you
missed in Stephen King's it trailer
here's a link if you missed it and in
that video I asked you guys to offer up
your input in the comments and I got an
amazing response you all had a lot of
insightful thoughts about the trailer
and things I didn't catch in my initial
video I've also been rereading the book
and it's been making me appreciate the
finer details of the trailer even more I
read through all the comments on that
video which at the time of writing there
are over 1,000 so huge thank you for all
the support on that one and I picked out
some favorites to talk about in this
video now a lot of you had interesting
ideas about the meaning behind all the
astronomy references and I'm going to
save those videos for the end of this
video because they may go in the spoiler
territory at least for the book but
don't worry I'll give you a spoiler
alert before I get there here are 12
things I missed in the Stephen King's it
trailer the biggest thing I missed in my
initial video was the setting this
upcoming film actually takes place in
the 80s apologies for that
misinformation on my part and thank you
to each and every one of you that
pointed this out in the comments all to
billion of you thank you for pointing
out that this movie takes place in the
80s a couple of you let me know more
specifically that the film takes place
in 1989 and this is backed up by the
technology you see in the trailer and
the fact that you can just look it up
online it takes place in the 80s but
what's more interesting to me is why the
filmmakers have chosen the 80s for this
film many of you confirm my suspicion
that the book will be split into two
movies meaning that the second movie
will take place in 2016 the same year
that are one within production when you
consider the fact that the first movie
is technically a flashback that kind of
makes this whole reboot series a
modern-day remake of it an interesting
choice when you consider the
significance of creepy clowns in our
culture today such as the Staten Island
clown and his many copycats over the
last few years we'll see if that plays
into the second film at all I'll never
forget that scene in the adult portion
of the miniseries where Ben notices
anyway
beside the road something that seemed to
happen quite a lot in America in October
2016 this is our next item the film is
scheduled to release September 8 2017
you might be wondering cz how did you
miss this it it says it right there well
it's not the release date that I missed
but rather the significance behind it in
the story it returns to the town every
27 years to terrorise dairy commenter
cynical cat lady points out the first
screen adaptation of it was first aired
in 19 and 27 years later the infamous
dancing clown is reemerging to breathe
fresh terror into a new generation just
as he does in the novel to me that is so
cool that's perfect timing for a new
movie I love when movies take real-time
into account in my video I mentioned how
penny wise his eyes don't show up in the
reflection some of you mentioned that
this could just be because the eyes are
enhanced in visual effects and they
didn't want to do the effect in the
reflection as well that is something
that crossed my mind having done quite a
bit of visual effects myself but then I
saw this comment which doesn't make any
sense but it got me thinking about the
novel and how it doesn't have a shadow
so maybe no eyes in the reflection is
the film manifestation of that or at the
very least one of those choices that
easy to make because you know it's going
to save you a lot of money in visual
effects oftentimes the reasoning for a
choice made in the film is something
simple like that for example I
questioned what that key might have been
around Beverly's neck a commenter named
when the sky turns dark points out that
it may just be her house key which she
needed to keep with her because unlike
many of the others she might not have
someone home all the time who can let
her in we already know her dad is
unreliable and she may just use the
necklace for the key because her dad
would beat her if she ever lost it
here's another thing I got wrong I
pointed out these flower beds in the
wide shot and said they were arrows many
of you took a closer look and discovered
that they are actually crosses while
we're on this landscape shot I have to
admire the choice of location this is a
town called Port Hope in Ontario Canada
one of the three Canadian cities where
the movie was filmed you can see much
more clearly here that they are indeed
crosses and as a couple of you
speculated that because of the church
right across the street
the park over here is called Memorial
Park and I'm sure there are plenty of
memorial parks across North America but
that is also the name of the optin
mention location and dairy in the book
it's more of a coincidence than anything
that would be super important to the
movie but I found it interesting
nonetheless another useless but
interesting location I noticed was right
across the street from Memorial Park
there's a restaurant called turtle
John's there are constant references to
the turtle in the novel and I'll
actually discuss that more in detail a
little bit later in the video there's
also this Canal which will play the part
of the offshoot of beacon dusky extreme
that runs through Derry not only is this
where Ben first meets Pennywise in the
book but I was checking out some of the
photos of the canal and it's shallow
enough to wade in
so I wouldn't be surprised if this is
also the location for the Barrens which
if you aren't familiar with it is the
place with the group basically bonds and
becomes friends when they get in trouble
from building a dam downstream again
it's not like a deal breaker for the
movie but it's just a nice touch when
the locations are actually connected in
a film especially one that focuses so
much on the town that it's located in
and has scenes that move from one
location to another there's also a
library right in the center of town here
which brings me to the next thing I
missed so in the miniseries Richie has
his confrontation with Pennywise in the
library which is obviously an iconic
scene in the novel however it's been who
spends all of his time at the library
especially before he becomes friends
with the other six kids he's at the
library on the last day of school which
is what it would seem they're depicting
here for the record in the book he's
also the one who goes back to the
library as an adult seeing as how it was
like his safe haven from the bullies as
a child the flooded basement scene in
the trailer sparked some debate in the
comments as to whose basement it was a
natural II thought it was the den burrow
basement just because Bill is down there
by himself when he encounters the
illusion of georgie some people
suggested it could be the 29 niebolt
basement i don't think that's too likely
considering the modern appliances scene
here and this guy taylor TV brings up
another good point which is that it
would make sense that he encounters
georgie in the cellar because in the
first chapter bill sends him down to get
the turtle wax which we'll get back to
essentially sending him to his own doom
in a way so it takes advantage of this
by using George's image in the basement
to guilt his brother seems like a
logical way of looking at it
okay before I get into the astronomy
stuff there are a few things that people
brought up that we're not things that I
missed but things that I didn't really
think anyone would miss so I'll just
list those off real quick this could be
the leper that Eddie sees at Twentynine
kneeble this could be a depiction of the
black spot fire it also might be a
replacement for the junkyard bird scene
I actually wouldn't really mind if it
was Bill doesn't stutter at all in the
trailer but I'm not too worried about
that I feel like the trailer was just
cut with good audio from him to make it
flow better with that out of the way
this next part is going to contain some
spoilers for the book regarding the
origin of it so if you don't want to
hear I'll see you in the next video
assuming we both survive okay so you
guys have been telling me that you think
the astronomy stuff is a reference to
the fact that it came to earth from
outer space this ties into the whole
subplot of how it in basically the
Stephen King equivalent of Satan and how
the counterbalance is the turtle which
is like the creator of all things
I'm not going to dig too deep into the
lore for the sake of simplicity but
basically what you need to know is that
both it and the turtle come from this
void in outer space looking at the
trailer with this information I started
to notice even more references to outer
space scattered throughout Gary there
were some people in the comments who
were not buying into this because of the
fact that in the first scene with the
den burro brothers bill seems to have
sealed Georgie's boat with gold flags as
opposed to the turtle wax that Georgie
fetches from the cellar in the book so
their argument is that the filmmakers
only really have a reason to do this if
they're not going to feature the turtle
and the ritual and stuff I don't think
this will be the case the ending of the
TV miniseries is widely considered to be
its weakest point and it doesn't include
the ritual also with this movie taking
place in a different decade it stands to
reason that different products would be
more relevant in another time period and
with the new time period comes a new
audience and new fans
so if you're in it fan new or old be
sure to drop me a like on this video and
if you're new to the channel my name is
CV and I'm actually the greatest
director of all time I know a lot of
people are going to get triggered by me
saying that but even Obama himself has
agreed so if you're into the scary stuff
then
to subscribe to see these world for new
quarters every week yes we're making the
jump to weekly content I was planning on
making the shift later this year but you
guys are killing it with all the support
right now you're just killing it like
John Wayne Gacy out the head so I'm
gonna try and push out the weekly
content a little bit early
I don't be mad if I miss a week in the
early going here and make sure you ring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive